[MUSIC PLAYING]
From the Royal Institution
in London, DemoJam.
Featuring designer of particle
accelerators, Suzie Sheehy.
Vision researcher
and engineering
lecturer, Ben Craven.
Protein crystallographer,
Stephen Curry.
The UK's coolest science
teacher, Jonny Berliner.
And your host, formerly the
UK's coolest teacher, now
stand-up mathematician,
Matt Parker.
Are we done?
We're done.
All right.
Now, ever since we had DemoJam,
well, this means the
Royal Institution is no longer
just for Christmas.
Lectures?
Oh, no.
No, no.
We've invited our favourite
scientists from right across
the country to come in, flop
their favourite demos out on
the table, amaze
us, educate us.
Whatever they're going to do,
it's going to be thoroughly
good, geeky fun.
And to start us off, can we
please put our hands together
for our very first DemoJammer,
Dr. Suzie Sheehy.
You would have seen one of these
Van de Graaff generators
when you were at school.
But if your school was anything
like mine, then once
a year, the thing got hauled
out, switched on, and
absolutely nothing happened.
Now, what's supposed to happen
is that the belt peels
electrons off the rollers, and
it builds up a positive static
charge on the top of the dome.
I've got a bunch of electrodes
which are hooked up
to the Van de Graff.
And when I switch it on, every
other electrode will become
positively charged.
And the rest of them will stay
at ground, or zero volts.
And my particle today is a
ping pong ball which I've
covered with a metallic paint
so it can hold a charge.
And when that sits on one of
the positive electrodes, it
becomes positively
charged itself.
And you should have learned,
around about the Van de Graaff
lesson in school, that
like charges repel.
So it actually pushes away from
the positive electrode.
And then, when it sits on the
ground electrode, it loses all
of that charge and becomes
neutral again.
But it keeps rolling across to
the next positive electrode,
and the cycle repeats again.
And each time this happens,
it gains a
little bit of momentum.
So it gets faster and faster
and faster, if the Van de
Graaff works.
So, if you'll all do me a favour
and just kind of will
it on with all of your will
power, I'll just switch it on.
It's all right.
You can breathe again now.
Now, it turns out, you can't
roll protons around in a salad
bowl, unfortunately.
You need to actually put them
in an ultra-high vacuum and
then use magnetic fields
to actually bend
them around in a circle.
Now, it also turns out that
a real proton is about 200
trillion times smaller than
a ping pong ball.
And it can't change
its charge.
So we've made a bit of a cheat
here, because we've kept the
electric field constant.
In a real accelerator, you have
to change the electric
field to keep accelerating
the particle around.
And you have to do it
pretty quickly.
Because the protons in the Large
Hadron Collider, well,
they're traveling at just
a tiny fraction below
the speed of light.
And the speed of light is
299,792,458 meters a second.
So, keeping that in time with
increasing speed of the
particles is pretty tricky.
And we're not just talking
about one particle.
We actually accelerate billions
or even trillions of
them all at the same time.
And they all have the same
electric charge, so they all
try and repel against
each other.
And trust me, that causes all
sorts of other problems.
So, as models go, this one is
a little bit simplified.
But there's two things about
real accelerators that this
can actually show us.
The first one is looking at
the shape of the bowl, the
curved shape, that's actually
quite similar to the way we
shape the magnetic field
in the type of
accelerator that I work on.
And if you guys want to google
it later, it's called a
Nonlinear Non-scaling
Fixed-Field Alternating
Gradient Accelerator.
Now the other thing which
relates to real particle
accelerators is the
power source.
Accelerators based on this Van
de Graaff principle were
actually the cornerstone
of nuclear physics
research for decades.
And my first publication, which
was in nuclear physics,
used a Van de Graaff
accelerator.
So to me, the Van de Graaff
isn't just an unreliable,
useless classroom
demonstration.
It's a reminder of how the
development of particle
accelerator technology has
fundamentally changed the way
that we understand the
world around us.
Ladies and gentlemen,
Dr. Suzie Sheehy!
[APPLAUSE]
That's fantastic.
We give you the Small
Hadron colander.
Now, if you're at home watching
this from the comfort
of your own computer, you might
think that DemoJam,
well, you think it's a short,
concise, fun evening.
Oh, no.
It's not.
We just edit it to make it look
like it's short and fun.
In reality, the show takes lots
of long, tedious breaks
while we set up for
the next shot.
So to avoid the audience
becoming too, well, irate, we
give them some busy work.
We're going to issue everyone
with two Styrofoam cups and
some elastic bands, and we'll
come back later in the show to
see what they're going
to make of them.
Now, however, can we get ready
for our next DemoJammer.
Put your hands together
for Dr. Ben Craven.
[MUSIC PLAYS]
In a moment, down here,
I'm going to show
you a little square.
And what I want you to do is to
tell me, in one word, your
first impression, what colour
that square is.
So here goes.
Call it out.
White.
OK.
So you think that one's white.
Well how about this one?
White.
Even whiter.
So maybe the first one
is not as white as
you thought it was.
Well, if that second one is
white, look at that one.
Okay.
That's really white.
And so white that we're having
to adjust the camera to take
account of it.
So, do you think that third
one is definitely white?
Yes.
Are you absolutely certain
it's white?
Well, look.
There's the white one.
Now, see this first one
you were looking at.
What color do you think
that is now?
Grey.
It's grey, right?
Let's take the lights up and
see what it really is.
What colour is it?
Black.
Now, a couple of minutes ago,
you were telling me
that that was white.
Now you're telling me
that it's black.
So let's see what's going on.
Let's have the lights
back, please.
I was actually giving your brain
a very, very difficult
task to do here.
This square is emitting
a certain amount of
light into your eye.
Now you're in a dark room, and
this is probably the brightest
thing you can see.
And so, your brain made the
perfectly reasonable guess
that this was a light thing
in a dark place.
But what the visual part of your
brain didn't know about
was the very bright light
inside the box.
And what it was actually looking
at was a piece of wood
painted black in a very
bright place.
I'm going to do a little
survey now.
Has anybody seen this effect
before, this demonstration?
A handful of people have.
Most of you haven't.
Well I'm sorry to say that most
of you are completely
wrong, because you've seen it
hundreds of times before.
When you look up at the moon
in the sky, it feels like
you're looking at a
light object, a
light-coloured object.
We make jokes about the moon
being made of cheese.
In fact, if I had a
piece of moon rock
here, it would be dark.
It would be something like the
surface of a road or a piece
of dark slate.
When you look at the moon,
you're not looking at a light
object in a dark place.
You're looking at a dark object
in a very bright place.
Because the sun is shining very
brightly on the moon.
So next time you look up at the
moon in the sky, I want
you to try and convince yourself
that you really are
looking at a dark object
in a bright place.
I've been trying for years,
and I've never succeeded.
So I hope you'll have better
luck than I do.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYS]
Wow, that really is
mind boggling.
And, actually, do you mind
if we have a look?
if you come in here,
right, you can see.
It really is that there's a
bathroom light and then just
some poorly painted
bits of wood.
That is absolutely brilliant.
And thankfully, because of this
bit of equipment, we now
finally have scientific proof
of the Jackson conjecture,
which states, it don't matter
if you're black or white or
some kind of intermediate
stage.
Anyway.
Now DemoJam would like to
welcome along Professor
Stephen Curry for a little
fireside chat.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYS]
For which I need to
be over there.
And now I'm over here.
I'm joined by Professor Stephen
Curry, who is a
structural biologist. And you
work on the somewhat dangerous
foot and mouth virus.
Yes.
That's right.
And that does sound
very dangerous.
Do you actually get
to use the virus?
No, I work in a laboratory
in London.
We are not allowed, by law, to
use the virus because it's so
contagious.
And we only work on small
fragments from the virus.
So you get, like,
a little bit?
We do, yes.
Like, just the foot?
Not quite the foot, but we
work on proteins that the
virus makes inside
the cell during
the course of infection.
OK, OK.
So you get a safe
bit to look at.
It's entirely safe.
You've brought in a virus.
And we couldn't bring in foot
and mouth, I'm afraid.
But here we have, now,
who is this guy?
Well, this is actually a kissing
cousin of foot and
mouth disease virus.
This is actually the human rhino
virus, which causes the
common cold.
That's the common cold.
Right.
Now, how accurate
is this model?
Well, this is a child's toy.
So it's not entirely accurate.
The real virus has no eyes, is
not covered in soft blue fur.
It's nowhere near as adorable.
I'm afraid not.
But it is still an educational
aid to some extent, right?
It is.
There is one feature which is
quite anatomically correct.
And that you can see on this
end of the virus, which is
that it has a five-fold symmetry
axis, which means
that if we rotate it 1/5
of a turn, then the
virus looks the same.
How do we actually
know any of that?
I mean, how do we know it's
shaped like an icosahedron?
Well, that's a good question.
Because this toy is actually
quite a bit bigger than the
real thing.
In fact, it's about 3 million
times larger than
a real rhino virus.
That's not bad.
That's better than the
proton we had.
Indeed.
But even so, it's too small to
see by eye, and it's too small
even to see with our very
best light microscopes.
You can get a fuzzy image with
an electron microscope, but if
you really want to see the
atomic details, which is what
I'm interested in, then you have
to use a technique called
X-ray crystallography.
And for X-ray crystallography,
you need X-rays
and you need a crystal.
I happen to have a crystal -
It's all there in the title...
- here.
Oh, yes.
So, this is a crystal
of quartz.
So it's not a crystal
of rhino virus.
You are all perfectly safe.
And what's interesting about a
crystal is that inside the
crystal, all the atoms are
lined up in orderly rows.
But the virus is not a cuddly
toy, but it's not a crystal
either, is it?
No, it's not.
But if we grow up a few
milligrams of rhino virus,
there are techniques which will
allow us to induce them
to stick together in an orderly
form that makes a
crystal of rhino viruses.
Right, so you get crystallized
virus.
Yep.
And then the fun begins.
Yes.
So, a crystallized rhino virus
would actually be an awful lot
smaller than this.
But the interesting thing about
the crystalline form of
matter is that if you shine
X-rays through it, then it
diffracts that X-ray off in
hundreds of different
directions.
So you put X-rays through
the lattice.
They get diffracted.
And you get your diffraction
pattern, over
on a screen or something.
That's right.
And then, that's not a picture
of the structure, but you can
work back, I believe,
mathematically, from the
structure that you see here to
the atoms that must have
caused that.
Yes, that's right.
So, we get spots
on a detector.
But in those spots is all the
information we need, thanks to
Fourier's transform,
to reconstruct -
I'm a big fan.
- To reconstruct the structure
of the virus.
And what's interesting about
that is that Fourier was a
French mathematician from
the nineteenth century.
He died, unfortunately, before
the X-ray was even discovered,
before the virus was
even discovered.
Why was he doing it?
Because he was interested in
the transport of heat.
He was interested in how fast
does it take heat to get from
one end of a hot poker
to the other?
Hot poker research.
Right, now.
You do all this.
You do the X-ray diffraction.
You work back.
You get the structure.
Now, I assume we're using
that to somehow
combat these viruses.
Yes.
So, if we can see the detail
structure, so the results we
get are much more detailed
than this.
We can see where every atom is
in the virus, and that gives
us a really detailed
understanding of how the virus
interacts with the cell, how
it uncoats, and the things
that it does inside a cell
to cause infection.
So if you understand how the
virus works, then it gives you
a way to develop drugs
in order to stop it.
So why have we not got a cure
to the common cold?
Well, the common cold,
fortunately for us, isn't a
terribly serious disease -
It is for me.
- By the time you develop
symptoms, you're more or less
halfway on the way to a cure.
So you're going to get
better anyway.
That's right, yes.
So all we get from knowing the
structure of the common cold
viruses is we can make slightly
accurate toys.
So if I -
You could say that, yes.
If you get ill, you can curl up
in bed and cuddle the virus
that is currently
infecting you.
That's just great.
Anyway, all the best with
foot and mouth,
which is a great sentence.
Can we have a final round of
applause for Stephen Curry?
[APPLAUSE]
Right.
Now that we're pretty much at
the end of DemoJam, we should
check back in with our audience
to see what they did
with those cups.
So they all have made Bernoulli
cups out of them.
So let's see how this goes.
Spectacular, it turns out.
If you're wondering how to make
your own Bernoulli cup at
home, then beneath me somewhere
is an information
box which you've already
clicked.
You can find out how to build
your own, successfully.
However, given that this is
the scientific process, we
need to end properly
with a conclusion.
And because we are the Royal
Institution here, we should do
it in an orthodox,
scientifically accurate method.
Which is, of course,
through song.
Ladies and gentleman,
Jonny Berliner.
[MUSIC BEGINS]
When I look at the world, it's
all black and white.
Like the black of the
sky and the white
of the moon at night.
But it's more than the
wavelength of the ray that
gives me sight.
It's the way that my brain
interprets the light.
But the colour of the moon's
not black or white.
It's in between.
And it's a matter of
psychology why
it couldn't be seen.
It couldn't be seen.
No, the colour of the moon,
it couldn't be seen.
I got a cold.
It hurt a lot.
I wanted to see the
rhino virus that
was causing the snot.
Looked under a microscope.
Nothing to see.
So I tried my hand at
crystallography.
Got a pattern of dots.
Didn't know what they mean
without Fourier analysis, the
icosahedron couldn't be seen.
It couldn't be seen.
No, the icosahedral structure
of the rhino virus, it
couldn't be seen.
[MUSIC PLAYS]
Now Mr. Van de Graaff would be
overjoyed to see his machine
spin a ping pong ball around
a custom blown
acrylic oblate spheroid.
He'd be even happier that his
technology can generate the
protons for the LHC.
That we accelerate and collide
with energy and find
fundamental particles that
couldn't be seen.
They couldn't be seen.
No, the fundamental particles,
they couldn't be seen.
They couldn't be seen.
Jonny Berliner!
And that, ladies and gentlemen,
is DemoJam.